in 1968 a group of innovative educators
founded the International Baccalaureate
or IB for short an educational nonprofit
organization based in Geneva Switzerland
its principles are based on the pedagogy
of Maui Torres ma Hyatt she believed
that all children should gain a global
perspective on our world before they
study at their own national history
children should further always practice
two languages to learn a second form of
communication and with it a new mode of
thinking inherent to the second language
schools that meet the standards can
partner with the IB organization for a
fee they can be certified and then offer
their students in international
education that is valid all over the
world the goal to provide kids with the
intellectual emotional and social skills
needed to live learn and work in a
globalizing world IB programs encourage
personal and academic achievement they
are fun and academically challenging at
first and highly demanding later
currently there are four different
programs one the primary years program
this is for kids between three to twelve
and is designed to encourage the
children to ask some of life's big
questions how does the world work Who am
I how can we build a sustainable Society
in addition there are six classic
subject areas such as language maths
social studies science art and physical
exercise to the middle years program
designed for teenagers ranging from 11
to 16 it asks us to understand ourselves
in a global context we learn about our
identity culture relationships as well
as globalization and sustainability in
addition there are now also designed
literature and health 3 the diploma
program this is a two-year program for
students aged 16 to 19 who seek a
certified qualification - and
a university or another higher education
institution in addition to six elective
classes
it consists of three core subjects one
extended essay writings 4,000 words to
theory of knowledge in which students
learn to reflect on the nature of their
own knowledge and three creativity
action and service to learn creative
thinking for experience and social work
for the career related program it aims
to prepare students for the professional
world and help them identify career
options to pass it students have to do
to complete diploma programs study
personal and professional skills and
advanced language and how to execute and
learn from a big project later they seek
practical experience to get prepared for
their first job or an internship today
around 5000 schools all around the globe
offer IB programs some IB Diploma
students say it is a very stressful
experience with little time for anything
else but studying all day and evenings
others say that it's hard work and
challenging but once they graduate they
look back to a good and valuable time in
their life what do you think about the
IB please share your thoughts in the
comments below
[Music]
if you like this video and the way we
explain the subject subscribe to our
channel we try to explain complex
subjects in simple language and cartoons
to support students all around the world
in their learning if you want to support
us you can go to WWE and Comm / sprouts
and donate just $1 from many fans makes
a big difference
you